for more on what's happening on the
ground I'm joined Now by our defense and
security analyst Michael Clark hello
again to you Michael let's start with
her son reports of a lot of shelling
there what is going on there yes I mean
the Russians are on the uh the East Bank
of the NEPA River and we always knew
that sooner or later they would start to
Shell curse on
um the city is more or less depopulated
now and there's so there's an artillery
battle going on either side of the river
the ukrainians are trying to Shell
Russian Artillery positions and their
technology for doing that their counter
battery Radars and their more accurate
guns are fairly successful at doing that
but the Russians have just got more
artillery they can always bring more
arturians so Kirsten will not be safe
until either the ukrainians can suppress
Russian Artillery or make the Russians
pull back about 30 kilometers out of
artillery range but to do that of course
they'd have to surround them on the
other side of the river they may do that
but that's a that's a big ask okay um
Don bass also some Fierce fighting up
there yeah what's going to happen there
because a lot of people say oh it's
coming to Winter everything's going to
wind down do you think that that's the
case no I don't think it will well uh
things change during the winter I think
the ukrainians will be anxious to keep
the the pressure on but at the moment
there is a ferocious battle going all
across the line of of uh conflict of
forward lines in uh the donbass and
particularly between satovay and cremina
and that's the main p-66 main Motorway
the front comes from Russia all the way
down uh north to south and it's a main
artery for supplies if the Russians lose
that and they've already it's already
cut between satova and criminal then
they've got to go Long Way Around
towards starobilsk which is about 30 30
35 miles further east because there
aren't that many roads in that area that
can take military traffic
and the fighting there is ferocious and
the Russians have put their airborne
troops that they got out of curse and
the good troops they sent them to
svatovi and they're really digging in
and we thought that this battle might be
over a couple of weeks ago but no the
Russians are making quite a stand it's
for Tove and the cremina and the
ukrainians are pushing very very hard
but it's ferocious these are the most
intensive battles open battles that I
think I've seen since the War Began how
many people are there losing each day on
both sides I remember Ukraine at one
point we're losing about 200 men a day
what's the situation they're doing some
report is much more than that um that
they're losing seven or eight hundred a
day and the ukrainians are losing you
know a fair number of troops as well
fewer than that but the Russians are
just throwing men into these Almost
Human wave attacks they've got you know
criminals in the front people that
they've brought out of the convicts that
are brought over prisons then mobilized
troops behind them and then regular
troops behind them and the regular
troops are called barrier troops and
their job is to Fire and anybody who
Retreats so the idea is you go forward
or you die and and this has caused him
huge losses and they can't sustain those
losses even if they don't value these
troops which they don't seem to they
can't sustain losses of that order for
too much longer it's so horrific it
almost seems beyond comprehension it
does it does we've seen it in other
parts of the world in other times of
History we never thought we'd see it in
Europe in the 21st century
okay and this is a parisia that's
jumping out at me at the moment we've
heard so much about zaparita and the
nuclear power plant there there are a
number of these nuclear power plants
across the country they continue to get
a cat attack do you think that they're
just going to carry on operating or what
will happen there yes I think they will
carry on I mean the nuclear power plants
are in some danger because not of direct
shelling but because the electricity
grid is being taken down systematically
by Russian attacks and the electricity
grid is fundamental to the nuclear power
plants and the director general of the
international atomic energy agency
yesterday uh grossier Raphael Grossi he
warned very clearly he said look there
are four big power plants uh nuclear
power plants in Russia so the zapariza
there's riveni uh there's konitzky and
there's uh pivdinov Christ
um it's usually called the South Ukraine
one for obvious reasons
but those four in the last few days have
gone off the main electricity grid and
they're only being served by
um uh by generators and exterior power
and so what are you saying you can't
carry on like this because sooner or
later there will be a nuclear disaster
if if one of those stations loses all
power for several hours there will be
nuclear accidents and he's calling on
the International Community to take that
very seriously and do something about
that okay just finally just talk to us
about General sirovakin he's the general
who's in charge of this event so now
isn't he across the country he's the man
who's behind all of this I mean it is
his strategies his our ministry of
Defense describe him as brutal and
corrupt those are the words they use for
him
um and he's got a very checked history
of borderline well criminality he's
accused of many crimes including
shooting Russians shooting Russian
soldiers selling arms and he gets away
with all of them or he's just regarded
as a disciplinary problem not a criminal
problem
but it but he is very clever and what we
see in Ukraine now is the most coherent
strategy they have had and so he said
look I'm not and this is one of the
statements he is believed to have made
he said I'm not going to waste Russian
troops lives chasing Fanatics who are
armed by NATO around a guerrilla warfare
he said we have technical means of
making Ukraine surrender and his
technical means are to reduce the
vulnerability of his own troops to get
them involved in in battles that he
thinks they can win and then to put real
pressure on civilian society which is
what all these attacks on the
electricity really do it's what he's
done in other places in Syria and
chechnya in the tragic civil war in
Afghanistan he's a very experienced
officer but all of his experiences are
from Ruthless civilian-based offensives
and that's what he does